what's happening there reject nation we
are gonna watch ourselves some brooklyn
nine-nine today if you guys can go ahead
and leave a like that would be super
duper appreciated i'm looking forward to
this episode it's called captain peralta
that's all you need to tell me to get me
hooked onto this for anyone who hasn't
heard this already full length watch
alongs where you sync up with the time
code for b99 or over at our patreon page
cover a bunch of shows over there as
well and the boys over at prepper and if
you were a captain we'd follow you into
the sea both of you boys sexy phillips
captains you let's do this
[Music]
jake you gotta see this there's
something going on here something a
little
hairy oh my god
i grew goatee and it looks amazing and i
know you can see it of course we can see
it charles it's horrible it looks like
you unclogged a shower drain with your
mouth yeah you look exactly like the guy
in the don't talk to strangers poster no
no i
don't come over here so i can take a
better look thank you captain oh no
jeffrey's peralta no
no
that's abusive that's not funny guys let
the man have his goats all right
physical abuse his face
cancel this [ __ ]
i want to ask you something but you have
to promise not to get excited and weird
i can't promise anything of the source
it's about restaurants
i'm so glad i didn't make that promise
we go to chava it's a hungarian
restaurant that serves talasir kobas the
platter of a thousand sausages
my dad's coming into town and we're
going out to dinner tonight why are you
going to dinner with him he hasn't
visited you in six years yeah he's busy
he's an airline pilot regional airline
he flies internationally
back to albany
[Laughter]
when i was a detective my old c.o jim
martins used to keep us on our toes by
having us solve brain teasers i thought
maybe you'd like to try one don't just
tease my brain captain really go to town
on it yeah
there are 12 men on an island 11 weigh
exactly the same amount but one of them
is slightly lighter or heavier you must
figure out which and what do these men
look like facially
it's unimportant so like tyrese it's a
land of tyreses
true
let's go there there is a prize for
whoever solves it first
two tickets to the sunday's beyonce
knowles rock music
concert guys my dad just texted he's in
the building skully stop eating terry
start flexing everybody oh no detective
jake peralta he's the captain peralta oh
no
bradley whitford yeah i'm jake's best
friend charles gloria pop quiz what's
shake allergic to bees and wasps god
didn't even include wasps
oh hey captain holt come meet my dad
captain peralta hello cap captain
oh golly
that's great anyway i'm not here to talk
about me i'm here to spend some time
with my boy
that's my point
you might as well save yourself some
paper and give up now sarge you know i'm
gonna solve this first you probably
can't tell but i am flexing my brain
like crazy right now
i think you two are the only ones that
can solve puzzles yeah what about rosa
gina and me is this how you want to look
remember when i took that sudoku cruise
i never even went on deck 100 bucks says
gina and i can solve this thing before
you two puzzle dorks
oh it's um
you're going down really not a part of
this hitchcock
well canadian customs found some
prescription meds in my board bag
they're accusing me of smuggling what
yeah i have no idea how they got in
there oh he wants a favor
jake i need your help that's actually
the reason i'm here that's the
reason
yeah
[Laughter]
the case of why he came to town i solved
it because he wanted to take advantage
of his son okay
[Laughter]
we all needed charles in our lives
canadian cops think that my dad used his
security clearance to smuggle in over a
thousand pills of turjidol canadian
erection medication very potent
what i don't need it
i love it
oh
yes hitchcock get it how did you read
these files they're in french scully
translated them for me when i was nine
my parents took me to paris and they
accidentally left me at the louvre by
the time they figured it out they were
already back in queens okay no one cares
about your boring wife scully
[Laughter]
here for you scully
you use the seesaw to press down on
their necks until fatty confesses
incorrect
[Laughter]
points for creativity though what do you
say there scully old boy look at this
nut mix
it's half-cast shoes
i hope we never land so loud
and i want to talk to your girlfriend
denise because she had access to your
bags not on the night in question she's
been spending some time at her place
relationships are complicated we cheated
on her a bunch and she found out okay i
deserve that charles i have cheated on
women in the past and on this one too
so seriously jake this is gonna be okay
oh yeah you're gonna be fine yeah no
you're going to jail we balance three
against three and if they weigh the same
we just what just happened
come on
i'm saving them from this weight
obsessed nightmare island by murdering
them
terry these islanders are delicious
cannibal terry
they found pills in his apartment jake i
don't know what he's talking about i
swear i don't know how those pills got
in my apartment they want us on the next
flight out and that bernard's is the
best poutine place in the airport you
want some no i don't want poutine right
now yes
dad dropped anchor at the commodores
club
someone is there even so how do we get
in there by wearing dad's pilot uniforms
ah no jake i just don't think he's
innocent i just think that he's you
don't want to be like co-pilot i'm in
oh golly
that half-tuck charles
sorry scully we only had two uniforms
it's okay for some reason all the fries
and gravy and cheese upset my tummy huh
oh
buddy
you've been an underdog your whole life
but you defied the odds by having others
secretly help you because you didn't
have what it took that's not my story
this problem is beyond all of you no one
solved it
believe me no one is more disappointed
in me than me than i
santiago
oh
amy
all right here's the plan we're gonna go
sit down order a couple of drinks grab
her fingerprints off the glass she
serves us and then measure her risk for
handcuff size ready yup oh
crazy flight oh hydraulics were loud
yeah
[Laughter]
do you know roger peralta yes yes i do
how do you guys know peralta i used to
fly with him back in oregon my name is
captain spike masters this is my
co-pilot wanda cohen i drive the plane
when he sleeps i also take care of hotel
accommodations where'd you guys say you
flew in from pacquiao
whoa
take your day
this is outrageous i demand to speak
with a commodore himself
this bottle is filthy with her prince
smirk that's why you're the pilot and
i'm the co-pilot copy that wanda
copy that
wanda cohen
you don't know what the solution is
excuse me here's how we cracked it i
took the photo of you demolishing amy's
spirit and made these clever t-shirts
that say hashtag nerd fail oh
your expression is the same as amy's
because you're both devastated that you
just let down your mentors i looked at
your calendar you're supposed to have
breakfast with your old cl you wanted us
to solve the problem before you saw it
she's right he posed that problem to me
20 years ago
every time i see him he asked do you
have the answer yet and i never have
those islanders and their pathetic
seesaw haunt my dreams they mock me in
my sleep
turns out my dad's side piece framed him
she was hella pissed cause she found out
about his real girlfriend and his other
side piece so yeah turns out my dad is a
great guy
drinks are on me
huh
where's scully
oh i left him again
when you see my dad walk in can you dim
the lights and play we are the champions
no i don't know what your dad looks like
i don't have the song the lights aren't
on dimmers
my dad just texted he's not coming
to jake's dad yeah
oh
i'm sure your dad has a really good
reason for not being here no don't do
that all right don't let him off the
hook that's what i've done my whole life
you know when he missed my 11th birthday
i blamed myself for being born on a peak
travel day oh you're a pretty crappy
father
and until you're ready to be a good one
don't call me also i'm taking your
captain hat because it's cool when i
want it
[Music]
[Laughter]
next round's on me it's the least i can
do for teasing your brains so
mercilessly so what are you gonna say to
your old ceo tomorrow when he asks if
you solve the puzzle
i don't know
thanks for bringing it up fun chad
oh
no
but i'm going with gina's suck and egg
idea you
get
the beyonce tickets
oh
birthright it was my birthright you
[ __ ]
boyle release them
[Laughter]
you did good work
here
is this an allowance are you giving me
an allowance no i'm paying the bargain
ah
right
robbie
oh
that's so sweet
how lovely who doesn't want a dad
yeah
i want it
i want it i want more dance
[Laughter]
two three four dads i have like five
dads at once the community of dads all
raising me there's anybody who wants to
hit me up
for me to call them daddy
i'll be happy to oh yeah
they'll do it for free
that was very touching it was what a
great through line when you have that
established shot where the captains are
next to each other and you really see
that all of captain holt like it's
already been such an ongoing joke that
the projection of not having a father
and looking for a father figure goes to
captain holt yeah and then they do a
physical representation of that yeah and
then it ends with oh yeah his dad leaves
him again abandons him again and then
holt is the one to say i'm proud of you
like that's such a straw yeah that's
such a strong through line too and you
include in ways that are just like
seconds of your show yeah it's really
the opening the start of the story and
the book and the ending button i think
it's really strong it's really graceful
yeah yeah man that was funny that was
really funny
um
having that dad who uh just wants to
take advantage of you only talk to you
when you need something
i know it's like to have family like
that
jaby kawaii oh man never ever just wants
to talk to me
or mentions that he misses me
or anything like that it only hits me up
when he wants money
he gives all of it to a character
not as good as support as a character
yeah yeah greg what videos can i cover a
chart needs more stuff quick i'm gonna
keep char happy yeah yeah yeah
unfortunate facts math is really funny
man that puzzle was messing with my head
and it was like how do you solve
something i was literally i was thinking
about the whole time i was like okay
wait a minute well i guess if one way
slightly more slightly less it should be
easy but how do you figure out who's the
person if you don't look yeah yeah that
was an impossible one to solve and i
wonder if somebody out there there were
two things i wondered in this episode is
one somebody out there must have solved
this impossible riddle and two there
must be a bunch of those nerd failed
t-shirts on let's see the people have
made it's nice to have scully actually
get a chance to show off some real
skills
i love those those uh just a little
character for his opera singing his
french speaking
yeah it was really funny yeah and
bradley wifford is always so good he's
he's just one of those character actors
who always nails it he always brings
like
he's always like bradley was saying
like that's the same thing with like
richard jenkins they're so good at
bringing like the familiarity yeah but
also playing different people yeah yeah
adding just enough to where it's like
there's a reason it was specifically
bradley whitford but also yeah this is
his take on who peralta's dad would be
yeah it's like a perfect casting choice
yeah i wonder if well like west wing was
the nbc studio 60 nbc yeah because
usually nbc likes to uh network networks
do this all the time yeah um or like
they shuffle out their players of like
hey we like them on these nbc shows
maybe we can use him he's got some kind
of contract or something i don't know
yeah you can see that a lot now on cw
and netflix especially
yeah networks are known to kind of do
that so you know seeing bradley whitford
my mind naturally goes to what other nbc
properties has he done and he's a
perfect casting i was surprised like you
know i wouldn't go jake i was imagining
something a little more sleazy
so to see like bradley woodford be the
portrayal of his father is actually
really good because he is good at doing
that like
oh you think he's being sincere and
loving but really he's actually
manipulating he's really good at those
roles yeah well that's the thing too is
yeah he he can he can bring that sleaze
but he's such a good actor and such a
good character chameleon that yeah he
can really smooth it over to charm you
even as you realize what he's probably
going to actually do and he's a great
comedic actor there there was a run i
think it was when jay
i think it was tonight show with jay
leno once to do a 60 came out there was
this bit
where
they were like matthew perry was being
interviewed
and then he came out on stage barely
whiffered
and like the audience was just laughing
at syracuse the whole time and they were
doing like a dramatic scene because they
were shifted because matthew perry
shifting into drama at that moment after
friends
and they just like stared at each other
for a long time in a really serious face
with the audience laughing and then they
like hugged but they never broke a smile
and to me and though what made it so
funny was just how serious they were
while an audience is laughing and uh to
that that that's always stuck in my
noggin because of the fact i'm like that
that must be really hard to do i've only
seen that once when i first aired but
yeah that's uh it's a memory i've always
had
um
yeah that's my memory brother wifford
[ __ ] west wing and get out
[Laughter]
what 30 seconds he had on the tonight
show with jay the most impact another
nbc show yeah
man
the whole
nbc universe peacock umbrella man yeah
yeah this is a really fun one and i
honestly i i thought there was a moment
where the episode was going to lose me
because part way through when they come
back and they're like oh yeah we solved
it it was that girl at the commodores
club and like you don't see it initially
at first i was gonna be like oh that's
kind of a weird way to tie that up but
then making room for the ultimate coda
with them where yeah he he stiffs the
party and peralta has to go to his place
to have that confrontation like i
thought that was a nice
little you know not like it's a serious
thing yeah it's like an actual serious
dramatic scene with some credence and i
liked like i really liked the way they
handled that and i thought that they
even though yeah it is like you know a
pretty broad comedy they brought it down
in a way that felt appropriate and it
felt like an actual moment of character
growth for peralta there's a good
attention and release of their comedy
when they when they bring back uh spirit
in the sky and they he grabs the
captain's hat and they go slow-mo yeah
that was a really good like unexpected
comedy beat yeah
yeah totally
well i had such a trope of like i feel
like i've seen a number like a lot of
movies do the slow-mo cool song walk but
i feel like i've seen it in airport
scenarios a lot yeah so yeah it's a good
pull for this i really love the bit
though of a whole constantly um being
disappointed in amy yes that was
hilarious like just these little things
he says yeah so that third line
of uh appointed an eye
is uh no it was the third i was the
first one well no the first one was
being let down by the riddle that was
the second one was one of the barbies
that that one like broke me so much oh
goodness yeah yeah yes
oh yeah she brought up the whole thing
with the captain
yeah
that was a great great little trio of
yeah fail moments
because you don't you don't see that
like you you see like you know how amy
will react but to do like a three beat
of
of uh holt be disappointed it was like
an unexpected moment i thought was
really really cleverly fleshed out he's
everyone's dad and then of course like
boyle um you know uh being
like you know he would take this really
serious and i like how he was right
pretty much most other than the case he
was right majority of the time yeah
first character i i guess i kind of like
that device too of like for a character
who can be so deluded about his own
circumstances he really can see jake
like even though his love for jake is
kind of absurd he also can see the
circumstances when they are actually
real and they are actually hurting him
this is impressive
sorry excuse me um whenever i go on a
run i get a
it's really like sort of cough a lot
yeah respiratory system it's just like
take it easy
you do this once every three months
you think you're going to do it all the
time
so yeah thank you guys for uh being here
leave that like
and uh hey let's do a page
chris swam off if anyone could be my dad
at my patreon page
i would say
it is you you be the perfect father
figure a you love helping people so much
you really get involved almost to the
point where it's a little obnoxious you
might want to dial it back someone's
going to take advantage of you
who better to take advantage of you than
your own son i would gladly take
advantage of you pops because knowing
how generous you are i bleed you dry
acting like i don't have anything in my
bank account but i would constantly go
to you for help and you would always do
it always wanting to do favors of like
physically helping me move stuff all the
time you would always be there dad so
papa chris what i gotta say to you is
thank you so much for loving me
unconditionally while i know how weak
you are to your son i love you pops
you're my favorite
i feel so neglected right now
chris wants you you have a real life
you have a real dad but it's not chris
wham-off diana humphreys my sister is a
great dad
all right
[Laughter]
taught me how to be a man just kidding
chris i love you buddy you're stronger
than i'll ever be
[Music]